Hôm nay, khi là Vũi Nguyen của Bé Phương Linh và Móng Mô tìm lớp học cho con học hay lớn mùi
và em đang có lớp nào phung đi.
Lê lầm của họ của rất nhiều các bạn Vũi
đã người về chỗ thầy
cũng như là người về cho hệ tùng phát bến của Vũi Tét Hành
để xa, tìm đi để tìm dãy đi cho các bạn
về các lớp học của thầy xong của xin học hay này
sẽ trở khai các mùi các bạn có thể học hay
để tìm dãy đi cho các bạn, rất là hồi rất nhiều các bạn
Vũi Nguyen của Móng Mô tìm cho con mình mùi cái lớp
để có các bạn thì học hay
và rất rất nhiều đoàn tập
và ở phương để học sớm lưu chính chính
Lê lầm mùi Nguyen của Móng Móng
để lê lầm mùi các bạn, mình mới ngớt
để xa
thì thấy có đi có lưu thật hỏi các bạn
cho các bạn cũng như là cho các bạn ủy quý khám khám
để có bầu quý người tham ra
và khi học của mình tìm dãy nhá
khi tà thì quý thầy hệ tổng khó của tầy
sau khi xong xuôi trong khoa xin học 1 t cửa trên trường thì có kì 2 sau thì mắt đầu hệ
chúng ta mấy mắt đầu học ở lớp vi hay này
thì các lớp là gì tinh theo nếu tinh theo 1 lục chiếc về đủ chung
bao ngon 1 khoa nếu tiếp được mấy giờ chúng ta có kì thi
có lạc khoa chuyên này là mấy một khoa lực này là một khoa chuyên này
có người làm bối có thể có thời gian này học những muôn học khác nữa nhá
có thể tinh thật thành nếu lạc vim
cho tiết trên thống muu của mình và xe nếu lạc các tất cả gặp bội lạc vim
nhưng mà nó tất cả gặp bội học
có nó thể bảo sau thì có thể xem con nhèa theo dõi qua mục
nếu bội học mà trước đây thì thành là tình dạc cho các bạn
để các bạn phương bị lửa quốc tìm của họ nào
lửa bộ mình rất là phụ viến hiện ra
không tưởng như họ học thêm mà các bạn có thể
đến lớt, đúng không?
khoa ngon nha quá, không biết lớt thì khoảng hệ bỏ lớt nữa bộ nơi
và không có gì để xem là
hãy xem, mình là nó phải mất công dịch chuyển
đúng nhá để trường, đúng nhá để lớt học
thì nó có mất thời gian
nhưng mà mấy giờ thì hãy thống họ học hong nha
thì các bạn có thể chỉ rất giả là gì
là bật, phải lên, mọi thứ lên để có thể thậm cùng mình thầy
thì nó rất là đơn giản như vậy
và cái thức lên thầy cũng như đang theo hong nha
có thể thầy thì có mặc vui hình khỏe đang kì học thông qua
khoa xai thưởng thành chứng viên
khoa xai này không?
các mặc vui ngôi thịt
tình bò thì mình khiến mất kiểmu này tạng nào
thì trên quếp xai sẽ ngó hệ thống
và cái hong nha thì có thể rất vui bình lộ xin
cũng như là bài bản chọn khó là
sẽ có cố lên
nhá, cố lên sẽ cố lên cho cố bận của quên
cho các con để cái lộ xin học tập
xong rồi nó phụ hậm nhớ
với tầm tại xin cũng như là
thức lực của các bạn
thì thầy xin chú cố bận của quên của các bạn học xin
sẽ tìm là khoa phụ hậm
không nhiều là đăng bị thành công với lệ thống của mình thì thầy nhá